ariana grande justin bieber and others
are set to cash in
following the sale of scooter bronze
ithaca holdings to seal-based company
hype corp
but they're cashing in a rather unusual
way through shares in the corporation
that manages bts the k-pop sensation
hybcorp which went public in october as
big hit entertainment
plans to buy ethical holdings for 1.05
billion dollars
the deal which is set to close may 7th
would bring in grande
bieber j balvin and demi lovato among
others
it would also see hype take over big
machine label group which ithaca
currently owns
hive's reason for buying ithaca is to
diversify its roster so its revenue
won't be so reliant on bts
in the first half of 2020 the boy band
represented 87 percent of the 290
billion won high
reported for the first half of 2020.
before the band hit it big each member
of bts was offered equity in the company
bts's current equity is worth more than
107 million dollars on top of the 107
million dollars they've earned since
2019.
according to the terms of the deal both
ariana grande and justin bieber are set
to receive 53
557 shares worth about 12 million
dollars
these two received the biggest payouts
of bronze artist
jay balvin the reggaeton artist who had
the third most streams in 2020 according
to spotify will get
21 423 shares worth about 4.8 million
dollars once the deal goes through
demi lovato whose album debuted at
number two last week will get 5
355 shares worth about 1.2 million
dollars
and for his part brawn is set to pocket
shares valued at more than 103 million
dollars
plus an undisclosed amount of cash
[Music]
you